also ich war ja derjenige der michael
beraten hatte wie er wieder am aus
deutschland wegkommen und an sein
ursprünglicher plan war bei laura nicht
direkt nach amerika einreisen konnte das
eben wieder 14 tage ein drittland
bereist werden muss so wie wir das schon
mal im mai gemacht haben und dann wollte
er tatsächlich von heute auf morgen nach
barbados um dort die 14 tage quarantäne
quasi abzusitzen und das konnte ich die
davon konnte ich ihn dann befreien weil
ich sagte nein du brauchst das gar nicht
mehr laura ist jetzt eine frau und du
kannst
direkt nach amerika einreisen und dann
ist es eben so im gebucht wurden dass
sie von heute auf morgen das land
verlassen haben und er auf dem weg zum
flughafen eben auch noch gesagt hat auf
gar keinen fall ist dann irgend jemandem
was erzählen und wenn es ein manager
markus krampe anruft sagt eben er ist
nicht erreichbar
und er wollte dann eigentlich schon
direkt nach landung das große presse
statement raushauen dass er eine woche
später gemacht hat also sie haben ihn
und laura am 30.09 zum flughafen
gebracht
lassen sie uns ein bisschen über den
zustand von laura sprechen über den
wendler spricht man ja vielerorts laura
was hat sie denn auf sie jetzt
persönlich führen ein druck gemachte
steht sie da an der seite ihres michael
wendlers oder lässt sich das irgendwie
ja einfach über sich ergehen vor sich
hin laufen also tatsächlich eher
letzteres die die fahrt war ungefähr
zweieinhalb stunden und während der
fahrt hat den ich viel geredet ihr war
ganze zeit schlecht und tatsächlich auch
zweimal während der fahrt die sich im
auto übergeben
ich musste an der raststätte anhalten
also sie wirkt irgendwo sehr sehr
beklemmend und fast schon so als wenn
das alles gegen den willen passiert weil
sie vielleicht die konsequenzen dieser
heimlichen
rückkehr nach amerika dann vielleicht
eher realisiert hatte als er mich sah
und sie haben auch noch wenn ich richtig
informiert bin das geld für die flüge
ausgelegte für die bei haben sie das
geld mittlerweile zurückbekommen man
also als reisebüro ist das ja nicht dass
man für die kunden dann die flüge bucht
und eine rechnung schreibt
und michael hat mir mehrfach zugesichert
dass er das geld überweist sobald er in
amerika ist er hat es nie überwiesen
letztendlich ist es jetzt verrechnet
wurden mit gegen gebuchten flitterwochen
weil die sind ja auch wieder stornieren
so dass seit einer woche das geld wieder
bei uns ist aber fünf wochen lang geht
das jetzt vorstrecken mussten und er
sein wort nicht gehalten hat
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren